generally you know you've grown up in
the states uh you speak Spanish fluently
you live in Mexico City right now I know
you've lived in other parts
um I think you've been to El Salvador
like where else have you lived in the
Latin world
uh El Salvador Panama for a little bit I
go to Columbia every now and then for
extended trips like two three four weeks
maybe yeah
um can you give them a little bit of a
like a sequence of tips that they can
follow that might be a little more
useful than sending money to random
people in Ukraine or wherever
um you know from your experience because
I mean you do really well like you're in
a group chats you know we talk privately
there's a lot of stuff going on in your
life you know with the Senoritas and
without giving away you know too much
um
you're a g as they would call it right
sort of thing so what's the deal you
know for guys like that
yeah first and foremost and Rich you
alluded to it earlier uh coming into the
top of the stream that if you can't get
girls at all in the U.S or your country
of origin then you need to figure that
out first because you're not going to
help yourself going abroad yes you may
be able to get girls but a lot of time
they're going to be the lower class or
they'll be the paid type girls or
they'll fall into this trap because this
guy doesn't see this stuff coming you
could tell when we freeze framed his
face that he's like oh no what is going
on because he doesn't have that
experience and uh in the U.S I know a
lot of times we throw around the idea
that girls can be ruthless but when you
go to other countries and there's a
large discrepancy in terms of income uh
they they do things that they wouldn't
do to the local guys or guys that they
actually respect
um so that that's the first one try to
get any reps in the U.S or Canada
wherever you're coming from I always say
uh it is a bit easier abroad that's
because that they see you as a little
higher SMB but if you're if it doesn't
really matter if you're a two in the US
it doesn't really matter if you're a
three or four abroad God you're still
very very low as they're very and you're
going to have that experience
and the girls are usually hire smv
abroad but you have to realize that
especially if they're more from from
more traditional countries they are
going to detest these beta type guys
even more than the American girls do
because these these foreign girls don't
know any better
um they not only does is she is she
playing him but it's largely likely that
she despises him and she and her friends
probably sit around and make fun of him
and oh ask him for more money and the
reason I say that is every now and then
I'll come across girls here that try to
do the same thing so I have certain
roles in my life that there's no money
involved no talking money no going out
not even any dates until we've uh we've
been intimate and it has to be genuine
burning desire at that point then yeah
I'll start taking them out I was gonna
ask you have you ever heard any feedback
from women that have dealt with like
dorks like this that like have you ever
dealt with a woman that's like sign up
for one of these match sites or they've
had expats try to come to them to meet
them or they've been picked up by how do
they react to them do they just look at
them be like you're low value why are
you here sort of thing or
I'm trying to think I haven't dealt with
women that have done any sites like that
I've dated a handful of only fans girls
here and uh one one of them we got we
got into it recently I might interview
her on my Channel at some point but uh
she's she's a really sweet girl and she
really thinks that she's helping these
guys and I told her like no like you you
ruined these guys and these guys come to
guys like me you were moff and we have
to start putting them back together but
um she she's a sweetheart she thinks
that she's really doing a good thing uh
another one that I dated recently she
was uh an actress years ago for a
reality show down here that was pretty
big so she already had a following and
then she she makes pretty good money on
there but she's irresponsible with her
money um she falls in the camp of where
yeah she thinks she thinks they're
pathetic it's just it's just a money
make maker for her it affords her
lifestyle and gets to send her on trips
uh and whatnot but that's what and that
that goes in general like any guys that
are in like red pill type ideas we have
the alpha F's and beta bucks equation
well that still exists it's just
existing through different platforms and
different channels this guy that sent
40K he obviously falls in the ladder
that beta bucks category and we can we
can see that so the rules still apply
abroad but there's different things to
uh let me get into consideration let me
just talk about the correct way to do it
this is my friend George Gammon uh
loaded has lots of real estate has a
place in Medellin this is how you
geolocate and you know you get what you
want where you go he's obviously having
a good time here in uh Medellin for
Halloween dress to the nines uh nice arm
candy with them and hanging out with
some cool people like this is the
correct way to do it
um money like you've got to have money
you gotta have the looks You Gotta have
game it's not gonna it's not like you
get on a plane and go somewhere and all
of a sudden your your status goes from a
two to like a 12. it doesn't work that
way I think it costs like a seven to an
eight or a five to a six or it's like a
seven to a 7.1 maybe and the girls go up
a point or two uh as compared to
American girls so for me I I notice my
status goes up up a bit but the girl
status like let's say my status goes up
one point their status goes up two or
three points so now so now I'm dating
girls that are that are higher quality
but they perceive me as higher quality
and I think that's the that's the sweet
spot to be in yeah
um you got a few other tips for these
guys while we're on it
yeah another big one is uh this guy was
saying a lot of times and Rich you you
nailed it too uh oh cheap hotel or oh
it's two thousand dollars I gotta work
really hard I screwed this up uh like
the first time I went to Columbia where
I went out and and with the exchange
rate uh this girl I was with she was
beautiful and I was I was saying things
like oh wow this is so nice it's so
cheap oh I could oh I could really get
ahead here they don't want to hear that
stuff because she's making like 400 a
month working some really stressful
corporate job and for me for me being
like oh we're going to a fancy dinner
and it's forty dollars for the night
well that's a tenth of her income and me
bragging about it so you know it's so
accessible so accessible and then in
another breath hey let's let's go
somewhere else or Oh California is so
expensive at that point I was already
making well into the the single six
figures and uh this girl did not want to
hear it I think at one point she
actually talked to me she's like hey
she's like we don't make a lot of money
down here and I really lied to you but
it's really turning me off don't don't
talk about money stuff
um also in general don't talk about
money stuff especially if she asks you
for money uh every now and then I'll
have girls on the regular they'll
they'll ask me for money and it's never
much but but I always tell them like I'm
not a bank I'm not an ATM if you need
money I'll I'll refer you to someone
that can give you a micro loan micro
loans are pretty big in a lot of other
countries and uh and we can do it that
way and uh and almost always she's like
oh no no no you're so cheap you're so
cheap and then you just you just cut
them off at that point because that
indicates to you that she doesn't like
you for you and for me that's a really
big thing I think that's where a lot of
guys fail would you take care of her if
she was like a regular long-term girl
that's in your frame and a compliments
your life like would you would you throw
a couple of couple of bucks
no because the girls that are in my life
longer term they usually start getting
other areas of their life together too I
have a former main girl she was kind of
she was younger she was kind of a party
girl or whatever when I lived in San
Diego she was in TJ and I'd see her at
least once once a month but uh but we
we've gotten closer over the years I've
known her for a while now and uh she's
doing really well she texted me the
other day and she's like hey I'm I have
like Surplus income what do I do with it
do I invest do I do this she opened a
yoga studio and launched like a like a
nutrition line she's um well she was a
bikini in Fitness uh competitor and she
did really well won a bunch of awards
and now she does some modeling and she
gets gigs up in La so she's in
California all the time but she's
starting to make really good money based
on Mexican standards now and most the
girls I've dated on the long term they
end up kind of feeding off of that
energy that I have and they get those
areas of their life together pretty
quick uh they're also from higher
classes so there's a there's a class or
cast system in a lot of these countries
too in Latin America it used to be race
based um basically the more Spanish or
european you are the higher cast you are
the more indigenous business or like
afro you are then then you're on the
lower class and you still see that a lot
uh in certain areas of society today too
so usually I date girls that are around
my uh my class uh social class political
class what whatever whatever that looks
like socioeconomic class that's what I
meant as far as the women go they're
like they're generally more feminine
they're not as oh yeah mouthy I think
um
okay so they're more pleasant they're
less disagreeable
um they're gonna be from what I
understand from our conversation a
little bit more compliant
they're receptive to male energy
masculine energy so you'll hear the word
especially where I live like much easier
exactly yeah yeah so they use the word
like machismo here which is I guess it'd
be equivalent to toxic masculinity
that's kind of the old school Mexican
way of doing things but most of the men
here uh I'm speaking men like guys older
than me they still they still embody
that so most of them have come from
intact families the dad's still around
they love their dad they respect their
dad they have Alpha Brothers uh or at
least more Alpha comparatively than the
us or Canada from what I've seen and
it's really important to look at a
girl's Inner Circle because if she if
she has grown up from the day she was
born to know to respect those strong and
powerful men in her life then it's going
to be a lot easier for you she's just
more receptive to to masculine energy
most of the girls that come over I don't
even ask them even if it's the first the
first date First Dates come straight to
the house uh second third date if I'm
vibing her then we can go out and you
know I'll spend some money it's not it's
not a lot here with the exchange rate
but uh she'll come over and she'll start
doing dishes and tie hiding up and they
want to make their presence in your
space known they'll always leave a bunch
of stuff behind their hair yeah I swear
they rip their hair out in the shower
they all they've always got hair behind
and the new girl always knows like whose
hair is this like oh it's your hair it's
like no it's not like you all have the
same color hair like there's not a lot
of blondes here yeah it's all black hair
um so game works the same if not better
there or is it work work worse like you
know what's your take on game there
I'm not overly gaming I never have been
so guys that are in the top one percent
or top ten percent I share a lot of
screenshots and how I set up my system I
set up a system to screen out girls as
fast as possible to only allow those
that are generally interested in me to
come through and I know that there are
some considerations there I do have
perceived higher s and v in this Society
than I would in the US but I still do
pretty well in the US too I I definitely
can't complain there
um and I have experience here I went to
school I went to college down here long
before Facebook and social media before
years before smartphones or Tinder
Tinder is still kind of a new thing here
not everyone's on it but everyone will
try it at some point whereas in the US
you know everyone knows what tender is
um so I do have a unique background in
that sense that I I went to a really
good school here I learned the culture I
learned the language and I'm able to
make jokes I'm able to do puns and
double entender as I'm able to talk
about politics and history and
philosophy in the language
um so in general I attract I I naturally
attract a higher class of women which is
local language
depends on what you're looking for if
you want to just come down and smash
real quick and have fun you can do that
there's go to any bar where girls know
that foreigners go to I went out I went
out the other night with a couple of
American guys and uh you find those like
where do you where do you get the
information on what bars to go to that
foreigners know that Americans go to uh
go to the expat groups uh you'll see
that most of the expats stick to certain
neighborhoods there's a there's like
three or four neighborhoods here in
Mexico City where all the expats live I
live in a pretty nice neighborhood too
but it's not known as like the Gringo
Hot Spot there's people from other
countries here Israelis people from
other Latin American countries it's more
like kind of the higher class people
live whereas the trendy neighborhoods uh
it'd be equivalent to more of like a
hipster type neighborhood so uh any any
tourist spots so if you go to like a
Cancun or by Arthur or something like
that then obviously there's going to be
bars that cater to the the tourism cloud
and or crowd and the uh and and girls
know that so if you go to a gringo
hotspot the girls are going to be there
intentionally looking for Gringos
normally they're not the hot they're
most attractive or highest class chicks
but coming fresh from the U.S especially
for guys that have maybe a little bit
lower SMB or still have some room where
they can improve there uh it will be
nice it will be novel but oh my God
these chicks are flirty and they're
feminine and they're fun a lot of times
what the guys don't know is that that's
their stick they probably got a new
Gringo every weekend because especially
here we are a bit of a status symbol and
that goes back to that whole previous
caste system usually guys of lighter
complexion the girls want to show you
off they want to put you on the
Instagram and they want to be like oh
look look at this Foreigner I got um and
even better than Gringo's uh European
guys here so if it's if it's their
choice between me and a European guy all
things being equal they'll almost always
go for the for the European guy although
a lot of the European guys aren't that
masculine anymore so uh so a lot of
girls I didn't make fun of them okay
um anything else you got before we kind
of switch over and take some q a
uh yeah let me see I got my notes here
um yeah in general they're they're more
traditional and I was thinking about
this in the pre-show so in Spanish the
word uh to have relations that refers to
physical intimacy uh guys in the know
know that if you're not having physical
intimacy with your girl you're not in a
relationship they kind of go hand in
hand here but uh in general sometimes
I'll throw the word relationship around
and guys would be like Oh I thought you
didn't have a girlfriend well I don't I
don't practice a two-way monogamy type
arrangement I do one-way monogamy I'll
have my main girl but my main girl's
essentially my girlfriend
um but in general uh and not even just
Mexican women uh just Mexicans in
general and this is for most of Latin
America uh they're still largely
traditional they're largely Catholic
that is changing uh I'd say they're
probably 20 30 years behind the U.S at
least here in Mexico City but Mexico
City is the most liberal city in the
country too just because it's a massive
Cosmopolitan conglomerate but in general
even all that being said I've noticed
that in general women can do
relationships better they have better
relationships with their co-workers with
their family we with their neighbors
with their Community everyone knows
their neighbors here and that extends to
you so even if you're just dating even
if it's just a one-time hookup she knows
how to relate with other human beings in
a much much more intimate fashion than
your North American counterparts and for
me that's really nice I grew up in I
grew up in a culture where it's cold uh
literally people are cold to each other
you don't really say hi to strangers uh
oh how's your day good okay cool yeah
bye
um here there's there's a warmth in the
interpersonal relationships and that's
something that I'd never experienced
having grown up in the states that I
really enjoy here and now I'm so
accustomed to it when I go back to the
US and I meet a girl even if she's into
Me You Can Tell She's faking you you
can't feel that genuine feminine energy
from her so I think in general just
they're more feminine here and that
means being receptive to male energy
that means being a little more
traditional uh they they're always made
up so even if she's coming over to spend
the night she'll put her makeup on
they'll take forever to get ready but uh
there's just little
little things they do here that they
don't do back home to where when you add
these very individual little things up
it makes a world of difference and a lot
of times most guys when they come here
I've had a handful of guys come and
visit like dude I'm moving here like
they just you just can't go back once
you've had a taste of something better
what do you recommend guys to check out
when it comes to like the Latin
countries that you've been at like is it
is it Mexico City for you where you're
at right now or do you have any other
preferences that you'd recommend guys
look at
uh if you're new to Latin America say
check out Mexico City check out some of
the popular neighborhoods like Roma
Norte condesa any of those that's where
all the Gringos go here uh you'll fit
you'll feel like you're still in the U.S
but there will be attractive Latin girls
around
um if once you start getting more into
the language and such I prefer the more
traditional cities so if it's time for
me to settle down and have kids and I
decide to raise them down here likely be
Guadalajara I went to a really good
school there and I have really strong
connections and it's a very
so it's a large town but it it's it's
weird because you'll run into people you
know all the damn time you can get
yourself caught up pretty quick and
there's there's much stronger Community
there Mexico City is huge it's like a
New York city so it's a little more of a
transient city um any of your any of
your tourist hot spots you can
definitely have fun there but realize
you're going to attract a different
class of women uh you'll get you'll get
you'll get normal girls at vacation too
but typically if they're higher status
in their their home City then they'll
want higher status guys abroad to uh
just being Gringo or just being a
foreigner often won't be good enough uh
or you'll get like the granola hippie
type chicks so it really depends on what
you're you're looking for any of the
beach towns um if you live in Southern
California a lot of people are afraid to
cross to Tijuana but Tijuana has some
really nice chicks because it's a it's
the world's busiest land Crossing it's
so a lot of girls from all over Latin
America go to Tijuana and hopes of
coming to the U.S so they'll come up and
go shopping in San Diego and then head
back so
um check out your border cities not all
of them are safe all the time I know
even recently Tijuana had some
coordinated uh cartel attacks and that
was a kind of scary for people that were
there but uh and then deeper into Latin
America so the the general rule is the
further you go away from the U.S border
into Latin America the probably the less
English you're going to hear the more
interculturally experience you're going
to need to be and then uh you're going
to need to know a little bit of Spanish
and then once you go outside the major
city centers hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out